In this final section, we'll build the final logic
for pausing our sequence, firing off the event,
look for player input, and then finally unpausing
the sequence.
So if we jump back over to our project, one of the things
that I just want to take a quick note to show that may be
different from what you have set up,
if you recall from the previous course,
we talked about binding overrides,
specifically being able to use the spawnable actors.
So if I open up the level sequence,
you'll see within our sequence, we have our character.
And we have this SKM bot that we
have converted to a spawnable.
So within the level, again, just kind of tucked off
into a small corner here, if I close our sequence,
you'll see that I've dropped in our SKM bot runtime.
And in the actual sequence actor,
underneath our binding overrides,
I've selected our SKM bot from the sequence.
And the bound actor is going to be this SKM bot runtime, which
exists in our world.
So if you don't have that set up and you play your sequence,
you'll notice that it doesn't look like the actor is there
or it's tracking.
Again, that's because within the actual sequence itself,
our SKM bot is set to a replaceable.
Perfect.
So we'll go ahead and go back down here into our section.
So let's go up to our level blueprint.
And we'll open up our level blueprint.
And we are going to go down below here and start
creating the additional logic we need to connect to our input
and activate our event.
So I'm going to drag my BP sequence manager
into our level blueprint here.
And first thing I want to do is drag off of this.
And I'm going to do a bind event to pause dispatcher.
There we go, perfect.
Now, in order to activate this,
we need to add a event, begin play.
Perfect.
And begin play, drag off and connect this.
Hit compile.
You notice here that we actually
need to create our event next.
So I'm going to drag off of our event here.
And we're going to add a custom event.
And we can give this any name that we'd like.
But I'm going to do sequence, pause, event.
There we go, perfect.
And then from this sequence, pause, event,
I'm just going to drag off and type in print text.
Now, this is purely just debug information.
So you see here it says development only.
I'll expand this out.
And this is just a way for us to get a little pop-up
on screen that, from this text, kind of lets us know,
hey, what's happening here?
So instead of hello, I'm just going
to say, pause event triggered.
And you can choose to have a duration, a text color,
whatever you'd like.
But this should be fine for right now.
Hit compile.
Our error goes away.
All right, perfect.
Now, if we were to play our event,
so if I actually play our sequence here,
we should get a pause event trigger pop-up on screen.
But of course, the sequence will continue.
So this next portion is going to be the logic
that we need to, again, talk in between the sequence manager
pause event, the sequence when it's saying,
hey, I'm firing off this event, and what we
want to do with that event.
All right, so now what I want to do
is actually put in our sequence 205 start.
So that's the sequence we're playing.
Move it down here.
And I'm going to drag off of this.
And I'm going to search for pause.
We'll do pause.
And what we're looking for is work here.
And pause again.
If you don't see pause here, so it should be here,
pause player sequence player, you
can uncheck content sensitive.
And this will basically search for anything
that is related to this node.
But we'll keep context sensitive on.
And we want this pause sequence player.
Drag this and get a little bit thinner here.
And off of our print text, I'll
go ahead and drag into our pause.
All right, so now what we have here
is that when we have our event fired,
I'm going to create this event.
It's going to pause our movie sequence player.
In fact, we could compile, save.
And let's go ahead and hit play
and just see if we do get this.
So I have our player run up.
Jump trigger our event.
Let the sequence play.
And if you recall, around frame 480
is where we should see this event fire.
So if we take a look in the upper left,
we should see our event fire print string display.
Perfect, there we go.
So our pause event has been triggered.
And you'll notice that the sequence sits here.
We are now officially paused in our sequence waiting
for player action.
Perfect.
Let's go ahead and escape out of there.
Let's bring our level blueprint back over.
So now what we need to do is after our pause event,
we need to add a gate.
So if we just type in gate, and we'll do this.
And essentially what this is going to do
is this acts like a actual gate in real life
that is waiting for some type of logic
to trigger this gate to open, close, et cetera.
So I'm going to take this enter.
And if you hold down Control, you
can actually drag off this.
So Control left click.
And we're actually going to do this as a toggle.
And we're going to do start close,
make sure we have a start closed.
And on the enter, I'm just going to drag back.
You can choose whichever key that you want.
But for this one, I'm just going to use the letter P.
Just type in keyboard.
And that should give us our P key from our keyboard.
So this is going to pause.
When our P key is pressed, it means that our gate is entered.
It's going to toggle it.
And then what we want to do is just
continue playing the sequence.
So I'm going to drag off of our sequence here,
so the sequence player.
And we're just going to type in play.
This is what we're looking for.
Play sequence player.
We can delete this guy.
Move this over and continue to play.
Hit compile.
Hit save.
Move this off screen.
And then let's double check just
to make sure that this works.
Our player runs up.
Toggle.
And then again, when we hit frame 480,
we should see our little pop up text.
Pause event is triggered.
Give it a second just to make sure.
We'll hit the P key.
You'll see that it unpauses the sequence.
The character runs off.
We resume controls.
And if we leave and come back, you
see that we no longer trigger it.
Perfect, this is exactly what we want.